so once again we've got one of these
stories where a Democrat says I've been
in touch privately with Republicans who
might turn on Donald Trump and actually
convict him if there were to be an
impeachment trial where the Senate would
vote this is Democratic senator from
Connecticut Chris Murphy he called it a
number of Republicans that he could
count on one hand so presumably not more
than five Republicans who he says have
told him privately they would consider
voting to convict Donald Trump in an
impeachment trial and remove him from
office
so let's be responsible let's evaluate
this carefully I must have gotten a
dozen emails about this over the weekend
because remember that there were claims
similar to this that ended up not coming
true between Donald Trump's election and
inauguration at the time there were
assertions made that there were electors
who were going to defect and deny Donald
Trump the presidency altogether
obviously didn't happen many of us have
forgotten about that already so the
question is are there really five
Republican senators that might consider
doing this one possibility is there's no
way to know because they probably are
considering this so secretly that
they've never gone public about their
concerns about Donald Trump or their
their complete and total sleepers we
couldn't possibly know who they are if
that's the case it could be any of the
Republican members of the Senate what's
the point of even speculating but let's
for imagine let's imagine for a moment
that the most likely candidates to
defect are people who have shown some
public departure from supporting Donald
Trump so that then we can assemble a
list of possibilities and then the list
is pretty obvious at least at the
beginning one is Susan Collins from
Maine on the one hand Susan Collins has
spoken out against Donald Trump in some
cases she's been one of the Senate's
biggest Republican critics of Donald
Trump but remember at the same time in
the end she often sides with Trump a
great example is with the Brett
Kavanaugh nomination where there were
people on the Left saying Susan Collins
is going to prevent this guy from being
confirmed to the Supreme Court and in
the end she wanted
along with it but Susan Collins is one
possibility another possibility a
Republican senator who might turn on
Trump its Mitt Romney Romney has been
one of the biggest public Republican
critics of Trump they've gone back and
forth publicly about their friends
they're not friends they like each other
they don't like each other
Romney wouldn't be a shock if he voted
to convict but I also think that much
like with Susan Collins even if they
don't like Trump they end up being loyal
to the Republican Party and if the party
remains loyal to Trump they ultimately
do as well any time that there's these
conversations about more reasonable
independent thinking Republicans we hear
the name of Alaska senator Lisa
Murkowski that's a possibility she's
been notably not commenting on the
impeachment hearings so far but it's
just speculation at this point because
her name always seems to end up on these
lists and then beyond that it's really a
lot of guessing there's Cory Gardner
from Colorado whose name is thrown
around martha mcsalley in arizona is a
possibility Tom Tillis in North Carolina
maybe David Perdue in Georgia but it
really is just speculation and in the
end these are political calculations if
there is truly a senator that believes
they are better off politically voting
to convict than not you might see it but
we should be super careful about this
because this is one of those things
where even if you get every Democratic
vote in the Senate which is it's 45 and
then you've got Bernie and angus King
who are independent but tend to caucus
with Democrats that gets you 47 and
imagine that you get every one of the
Republicans I just mentioned right
imagine you get all seven Collins Romney
Murkowski Gardner mcsalley Tillis and
Perdue that's 54 you still need 67 to
convict on impeachment in the Senate so
in the most optimistic scenario where
every Democrat plus the two independents
plus these seven very speculative
Republicans all vote to convict you're
still short by 13 now the argument would
be if there are seven Republicans
already considering it and we don't know
that there are and all seven were to do
it then it might provide cover for other
look ins to jump in and then before you
know it you've got an impeachment
conviction with 2/3 of the Senate I
don't see that as happening primarily
because I don't see an impeachment
conviction vote being politically
advantageous to that many Republicans
unless public opinion drastically
changes 62% of Trumpets said no matter
what Trump does no matter what happens
no matter what he says I'm not going to
reconsider my support for Donald Trump
if that's the case you might be able to
find a few Republicans who are in
districts where okay maybe Republicans
there what the Republican senator to
vote to convict on impeachment you're
not going to get to 67 and that's not
going to translate to remove removing
Donald Trump via impeachment I want to
be wrong we can hope Chris Murphy
statement is very interesting but when
you really analyze it I'm not seeing a
path so this is a viable reality I would
love to be wrong and I would love to
hear from you about how I'm wrong or at
least potentially wrong let me know
leave a reply if you're watching on
youtube send me a tweet at D Pakman